every death is a tragedy and these
numbers demonstrate that this country
remains in the grip of a pandemic
my thoughts go to all of those who have
lost loved ones
the sacrifices that millions of you are
making day in day out
are starting to make a difference and by
staying at home
you are helping to keep those you care
about safe
and also contributing to this national
effort
but there is still a small minority who
refuse to do the right thing
and to them my message is clear if you
don't follow these rules
then the police will enforce them police
officers are now moving more quickly
to handing out fines when they encounter
breaches
and they have my absolute backing in
doing so
as we have done throughout this pandemic
we are constantly reviewing
our approach to ensure that we can crack
down on those most serious cases of rule
breaking
and today i can announce that next week
we will be introducing
a new 800 pound fine for those attending
house parties
which will double for each repeat
offense to a maximum level
of 6400 pounds
these fines will apply to those who
attend illegal gatherings
of more than 15 people in homes
the science is clear such irresponsible
behaviour poses a significant threat to
public health
not only to those in attendance but also
to our wonderful police officers
who attend these events to shut them
down
from the outset we have given the police
and necessary powers to enforce the
rules
which are in place to stop the spread of
this virus
and as these latest measures will
demonstrate we will not stand by while a
small number of individuals
put others at risk i want to take this
opportunity to pay tribute to our police
forces and our fire services for their
extraordinary contribution throughout
this pandemic
they're out there every single day
supporting our communities
you